The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
So welcome back.
We talked last time about the
problem of policy evaluation,
which was, given I'm
executing some policy pi,
estimate the cost to go, right?
And we showed that it
was sort of trivial to do
if you have a model.
And if you don't
have a model, you
can still do it with the
temporal difference learning
class of algorithms, which
is TD, which is in the title
there, OK?
And the temporal
difference learning,
the TD, lambda, in
particular, was nice
because it encapsulated
all the algorithms
we talked about last time.
TD, if lambda is
0 was essentially
the one-step
bootstrapping idea, we
said, where you use your
current cost plus your expected
value of all future costs as
your new estimate of this.
And the other
limiting case was TD1,
which resulted in just
Monte Carlo evaluation.
And what I said quickly at
the end of class is that--
we spent all our time last
time on doing temporal distance
learning just on the
representation of solving
a Markov chain, right?
We did it for discrete state,
discrete action, discrete time.
And it's known that
these algorithms converge
to the correct
estimate if you run
enough times and your
Markov chain is ergodic,
if you visit all states
at all times, OK?
But that's pretty
limiting because in order
to do a Markov chain analysis
of even an acrobot or something,
you have to democratize four
state variables-- theta,
theta dot, theta 1, theta
2, theta 1 dot, theta 2 dot.
So you do 25--
I mean, things get big fast.
It'd be the 25 to
the 4th power if you
put 25 bins in each dimension,
and that's not very many.
So today, we want to make
the tools more relevant, more
powerful, by breaking
this assumption that we're
in a Markov chain, where
we've discretized everything,
and try to do more general--
try to do temporal
difference learning
on a more general class
of functions that are
more natively continuous, OK?
So we're going to do it
with function approximation.
Now, to get there--
John did a little bit of
function approximation
in the reinforce lectures, so
I want to basically pick up
on the kind of examples
he was showing you,
and do a quick crash
course on least
squares function approximation,
just to make sure
that people are
comfortable with that,
and we'll build on that quickly.
OK, so let's talk a
little bit about least
squares function approximation.
OK, so the canonical example,
which is the same thing
that John showed you in class,
is we want to approximate,
or we want to estimate, some
unknown function that takes
input x and spits out output y.
And you're given
input/output data, which
we can write something like--
you're given pairs
of data, samples
of the input and output.
So you're allowed to
query the function.
Given this input, what
output should you do?
In the basic case, you're
doing this passively.
Someone just gives
you a data set,
and you're supposed
to then do your best
job at reconstructing F, OK?
There are interesting cases
that people look at where,
if you're allowed
to choose this, then
how do you actively
interrogate the system?
How do you pick the x's to get
the most information output?
In the simple case,
let's just say
you're given a collection
of input/output data,
and you want to estimate F.
So the standard way to do
this is to write down--
there are many cost
functions you could use,
but the one most people
use is to write down
a least squares
cost function, where
we're going to try to find a
model where y hat is some F of,
let's say, it
depends on parameter
vector alpha, hat of x.
Just like in the policy
gradient kind of case,
I'm going to write
down a set of functions
where the actual function
depends on both alpha and x,
but we can think of
it as taking x's input
and generating an
estimate y hat, OK?
And you can formulate the
problem with the least squares
metric, where you're
going to minimize,
over alpha, the squared
error over my data
minus my estimator.
I actually have
the estimator here.
No big deal, but just to keep
it consistent with my chicken
scratch notes.
OK?
So if we can write down
a class of functions
we want to search over,
then we can turn it
into the standard optimization
we've been doing throughout,
where we just try to find
the parameter vector alpha,
which makes our estimates
as close as possible,
in the least squares sense,
to the actual data, yeah?
Or y hat here is F hat alpha xi.
OK, so why do we care
about doing that?
The methods used-- you already
know optimization methods.
We know a lot of ways
that we could potentially
try to solve this.
So for instance, we
could take the gradient
of this with respect to alpha
and do gradient descent, which
is exactly what John was
doing in the reinforce case,
except the gradient was
not calculated explicitly.
It was estimated by sampling
in the reinforce case, right?
And in general, there
are some cases--
there are some classes of
functions that we can choose,
and I'll make this
more graphical
and explicit in a second,
where you can just
solve it analytically, right?
Same way in the optimal
control derivations,
there were some u's
that we could just
derive analytically
and some that we
had to do gradient descent for.
So let's dig in now
and get more specific
and say, what kind
of models do we
want to use as candidates
for these functions
we're trying to fit?
How would we write
down an F hat, which
depends on both alpha and x?
The literature is just filled
with people's different models
that they do this.
One of the most popular ones
of, let's say, 20 years ago,
which actually are
still popular today,
and we call them
function classes.
One of them is neural networks.
So a lot of people
believe that a good way
to write down an arbitrary
function is to take your inputs
and try to do something
that models a neuron.
It adds things up.
Adds up the different
inputs, and then
goes through a
sigmoidal function
and gives you an output y.
Maybe just because that's what
the brain sort of does, maybe
because there's a lot of
success stories from it,
but a lot of people
do this, right?
And moreover, this is sort of
the single layer neural network
if you have lots of
different input functions.
And they potentially add
up to y, for instance.
And the parameters now are the
weights of this connection.
So your function might be
some squashing function,
this nonlinear function,
times a weighted combination
of the inputs, potentially
plus some baseline or something
like this, where this
is tanh or some function
like that that does a sigmoid.
OK.
And if you do this, then you
can stack things up and make
multiple-layer neural networks.
And people believe, and
people certainly in the '80s
very strongly believed, that
this is a representative class
of functions that maybe
looked a little bit like what
was going on in the brain.
And people know that if I have--
it's a general
function approximator.
If I have enough of these
neurons and enough layers,
then I can represent any
function arbitrarily finally.
So it's kind of a
cool result state.
Using this thing that
looks like the brain,
if I stack up these
elements, then I
can represent any function
with enough neurons.
And if I want to solve a
least squares optimization
problem to make the input and
output of this neural network
work the same, then I can just
solve this optimization problem
with gradient descent,
and that's roughly
what everybody did in the '80s.
I guess that's not
quite fair, but--
right?
And it works, actually.
People still use these today
to do face recognizers, right?
They use it to--
Yann LeCun down at NYU has
got this text recognizer
that they use actually to scan--
to read checks at
the bank, right?
That's still neural
network-based, OK?
A lot of people
got a lot of things
to work with these
neural networks.
Gerry Tesaro, in the
optimal control sense,
got the TD gammon--
the reinforcement
learning system
to play gammon, where the
board configurations were
put in as inputs to
the neural network,
and the output was what
move you should take,
and he got that to work, right?
And actually, there was a
value function that came out.
He would even explicitly
estimate the value function.
But today, this is
a strawman because I
don't like neural networks.
They're not a particularly
nice least squares thing
to optimize.
We can do better these days.
I just wanted to
put it up there is
an important element
of the class,
but not one we'll
tend to use, OK?
If you care about least
squares function approximation,
there are a lot of
other choices you
can have for your function f,
which you can parameterized
by alpha, which maps x to y.
A lot of choices, OK?
The ones that people in
reinforcement learning
tend to use most effectively
are the linear function
approximators.
Linear here,
meaning that they're
linear in the parameters,
but not necessarily
linear in the outputs.
So I want yi hat to be
some linear combination
of potentially non-linear
basis functions of xi.
OK.
So the neural networks
had the problem
that they were rich because they
have nonlinearities in them,
and if you cascade
nonlinearities,
you can get arbitrarily
rich things.
But the parameters that
change the function
are buried deep inside
the nonlinearities, OK?
It turns out, if you come
up with policy and function
classes that can represent
your problem nicely,
where the parameters
are all at the output,
then life gets a lot better, OK?
Why does life get a lot better?
Well, because now I can take
this least squares metric
and solve it explicitly
for alpha, OK?
There's two things.
I can represent arbitrary
non-linear functions
if I have the right basis set.
Also, compute alpha explicitly.
Don't have to do
gradient descent.
I can just find the optimum.
Just to see how that goes--
you can probably see
it, but it's so simple,
we'll write it out here.
If I want to minimize
that squared error,
I minimize over alpha, sum over
i of yi minus alpha transpose.
I'll write the vector form
of that v of xi squared.
I could write this
even more vector form
if I choose big Y to be y--
if I put these things
into a big vector,
and big phi is in
the other direction,
then I can write this guy as min
over alpha y minus phi alpha.
If you take the gradient
with respect to alpha,
what do you get?
You get negative phi transpose
y minus phi alpha equals 0.
Assuming that this
thing is well-behaved,
then you can just say alpha is--
very straightforward
least squares
estimation with
linear approximators,
but let me now convince
you just how rich
that class of functions is, OK?
OK.
Here's the game.
There's some
function that exists.
This is my actual f, OK?
I don't know it.
My algorithm that I'm about
to do doesn't know it,
but that's the original f
I'm trying to estimate, OK?
And let's say I don't
get to experience f,
but I get to sample from f,
and every time I sample from f,
I get some noise, right?
Then maybe my input/output data
might look something like this.
This is just--
I took a bunch of
random x's, I evaluated
what that function was,
and I added a little bit
of random noise to it, OK?
Now the question is, if I
just have those red data
points as input/output
data, can I
come up with an
estimate in f hat, which
reproduces the original f?
And that's not many
data points, right?
OK.
I could do it with
a neural network,
but without telling
you all the details,
it's not quite as elegant.
We did it with reinforce.
It took a little
bit of convergence.
If we do it with a linear
function approximator,
we can do it just in one
shot, just like that.
The first trick,
though, is we have
to pick our basis set, phi, OK?
You've got lots of
choices with phi.
Some of the common ones--
let me do-- one common one is
radial basis functions, where
you assume phi of x is
just some Gaussian, right?
phi i of x is just
a Gaussian function.
The normalization
doesn't matter.
x minus mi squared to sigma i.
It's just a collection
of Gaussians
where the means are different
for every basis function, OK?
The variances could
be different too.
That doesn't matter.
So that might look like this.
If I made 10 different basis
functions for this problem,
and I centered them
evenly across the space
that I sampled for,
then that would
look like a reasonable basis
set for function approximation.
OK.
And then the question is, can
I take a linear combination
of that 10 Gaussians and turn
it into a pretty good estimate
of the original function just
from looking at the red points?
OK?
If I plug this
equation in, then I
can get a weighting on each
of those individual phis.
Alpha i is the weight
on phi i, right?
I'll do that with
another click here.
And it turns out
it said, in order
to represent this function, that
one that was centered around 0
had better have
some negative value.
The one that was
centered around 1
has got a pretty
big positive value.
This one's got a pretty big
positive value and so on.
So you can see all the
same Gaussians are there.
They're just weighted by
a different amount, OK?
And if you sum all
those up to estimate y,
then what do you get?
Pretty good, right?
It's pretty sparse
set of data points.
Pretty sparse set
of basis functions
gets a really nice
accurate-- in one shot.
No gradient descent or anything.
This is consistent with
what John and I have
been saying, don't do
reinforce unless you have to.
Because if you know
the function and you
can sample from the function,
you can just explicitly get it.
OK.
The barycentric interpolators
that we talked about before--
remember, we interpolated
between elements of the grid
with barycentric interpolators.
Those are linear
function approximators,
where it turns out,
you can think of that
as having nonlinear
basis functions, which
have something like this,
the whole thing rectified.
Essentially, if I plot
it in 2D here, then--
if I turn my radial basis
functions off and do
my barycentric interpolators,
and I run that same demo,
the barycentric
interpolators are
going to look like that, OK?
If I want to linearly
interpolate between all
these neighboring
points, one way
to view it is I take my
distance between the points,
I interpolate.
Another way to view
that is actually,
those are basis functions
that look like tents.
And the same thing is true
in 2D, they're 2D tents, OK?
It's the opposite way
to think about it,
but those barycentric
interpolators
we've been using the
whole time are exactly
linear basis functions.
And again, I can
sum these guys up,
and I can make an approximation
of the original non-linear
function.
This one, of course, has
got to be piecewise linear,
but that's OK.
It did a pretty good
job, considering
it's piecewise linear and it's
not a piecewise linear thing
it's estimating.
OK, you could do basis
functions based on Fourier
decompositions, for instance.
You could do polynomials basis
functions, where phi i of x
is x to the i
minus 1, let's say.
Something like that.
All these things work.
I'll do the Fourier one here.
Same function, noisy data.
There's a Fourier basis over--
spatial Fourier basis.
I can add those up.
I get very large coefficients.
These tend to cancel
themselves out a lot,
but still, I get a pretty
nice representation.
OK.
So this idea of using linear
function approximators
and then linear least square--
exact least squares solution
is a very powerful idea.
You can represent very
complicated functions
potentially with this.
This was not the
way people tended
to do things 15, 20 years ago.
It really tends to be the
way people do things now.
In fact, machine
learning got on this kick
in statistical learning theory.
People talk about
kernel methods,
and you might know these.
I mean, the essential idea
is there's two problems.
I didn't say it,
but sometimes people
are trying to estimate scalar--
continuous-valued outputs.
Sometimes, people are trying
to do Boolean outputs.
They would call that a
classification problem.
There's different
forms of this problem.
But in machine learning,
people realized
that you can often take a
fairly low-dimensional problem,
blow it up into a very
high-dimensional space using
lots of basis functions,
for instance, lots of kernel
functions, and then
do linear least
squares in the
high-dimensional space,
and that works a lot better than
doing some sort of nonlinear
gradient descent-based
estimation
in the low-dimensional
space, OK?
So that's really a trend that
happened in machine learning.
In reinforcement learning, it's
the norm because essentially,
when we have linear
function approximators,
we have some proofs
that our optimal control
algorithms are going to converge
when we have almost nothing.
In fact, in the more nonlinear
function approximator case,
we have lots of
examples where things
like TD on a
function approximator
just don't converge.
There are simple
examples where they
do exactly the wrong thing.
Good.
So just to convince you of one
more basis function that is
more relevant to this class--
that was just the crash course
for people who haven't seen
function approximators--
let me give you another example
from system identification.
Let's do nonlinear
system identification
as a least squares problem with
linear function approximation.
So let's say we've got
our equations of motion,
which come from this.
It's been a little while
since I wrote these equations.
Jeez.
Let's say it's for the
pendulum or for the acrobot,
you name it.
And let's say we know
the form of the equation,
but we don't know
the parameters.
We don't know how
much the masses are,
how long the link lengths are.
Normally you can measure those.
But inertias, things
like that, these
can be harder to get right.
So we can, for instance,
run a bunch of trials
with some dumb open
loop controller.
Just pick you
randomly, let's say,
and make the acrobot
flail around a little bit
and collect data that
looked like this, right?
q, q dot, even q double dot,
and u at every instant in time.
And this is going to be exactly
like our input/output data
in our least squares
formulation, OK?
And here's the very
amazing observation.
This one really surprised
me when I first got it.
The manipulator equations
for random robot arms,
they're actually linear
in their parameters.
Very non-linear functions.
They do very
complicated dynamics.
But they tend to be, for
most robot manipulators--
robotic arms on the factory
floor, walking robots,
things like that--
those equations
actually turn out
to be linear in the parameters.
They're not linear
in q, but they're
linear in the parameters.
All right.
Take the simple pendulum.
I can rewrite this dynamics
as alpha transpose times
theta double dot, theta
dot, sine of theta equals u,
where alpha is i, b, and mgl.
OK, after you think
about it a little bit,
it turns out to be not
all that surprising.
In all our robot manipulators,
you see sine thetas everywhere.
You see sine squared thetas.
You see sine cosines.
You see all these things.
You never see sine l theta
or something like that, OK?
It turns out, in these problems,
that the parameters don't end
up inside your nonlinearities.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't
it still nonlinear
because the parameters
are multiplied together?
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, good.
So it's not linear in
every individual parameter,
but I can get--
I can re-estimate this
as a linear optimization.
So that's exactly right.
So sometimes, you have to
settle for groups of parameters.
But those groups of
parameters are always
enough to rewrite your
initial dynamics, OK?
OK, so that actually makes
it sound like sys ID is easy.
If we have a complicated robot--
yeah, says Michael, who's been
doing it for the last three
months, six months, maybe.
I don't know. (LAUGHS) You
just shot daggers at me there.
Yeah, so sys ID should
be easy for robots
that are well-behaved.
It turns out, if
you have saturations
in your motor and stuff like
that, it gets more complicated.
Michael could tell
you all about it.
But if I have a
simulation of a pendulum,
let's say, then it should be
trivial, and it is trivial.
So let me just show you that.
It turns out, it's exactly
the same linear function
approximation.
This is my basis
functions, right?
These are my phi's.
I've got three basis functions.
One is theta double dot, one is
theta dot, one is sine theta.
These are my
coefficients, alpha.
And how am I going
to do it here?
Where is it?
Sys ID, yeah.
Just a few lines there
of the Matlab code,
and that includes
running the tests, OK?
So most of this is just
setting up my simulator.
I'm going to pick some small
random actions, a random tape
of torques to play out.
I'm going to pick some
random initial condition.
I'm going to run
my control system
with just making that tape--
a zero-order hold
on that tape, OK?
And I'm going to collect
the time x torque
and x dot that came
out of that simulation,
and do exactly the math
I showed you over here,
where alpha is i, b, mgl--
in this case, it's the location
of the center of mass--
and do my optimization like
that and watch what happens.
What's it called?
OK, so I started from
random initial conditions.
I play a small random tape
for 10 seconds out, OK?
The actual parameters that
I started with were this.
The ones that are
estimated after 10
seconds of running my simulation
and doing least squares
are that.
It's pretty good, right?
And that was corrupted by noise.
Not a lot of noise,
I guess, but noise.
It's easy.
System identification's
easy, right?
It's actually a very,
very powerful observation
that you can do system
identification for these really
hard systems just as a linear
function approximation task.
One shot.
That's what makes
adaptive control tick
on a lot of these
manipulators, right?
It's a very fundamental
observation.
AUDIENCE: What would happen
in the case you assigned theta
to a theta?
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, it's not going
to work as well, but let's--
it's running some random
initial tape here.
It's not catastrophically
bad, actually.
AUDIENCE: We have
this small angle.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Exactly.
That one happened to be
a small angle, right?
Let's see if I get--
come on.
That's a bigger one.
That's worse, yeah?
There's another way I can break
it, just to anticipate here.
Let me put it back
before I forget.
This was sine here, right?
What if I don't put enough
control torque in, OK?
I put a note to myself,
if I make a 0.1 here,
then suddenly, I'm not putting
in very much control torque.
And why could that be a problem?
AUDIENCE: Unprotected.
RUSS TEDRAKE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: You're unprotected.
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, I'm
sort of not-- exactly.
I'm not simulating the
system beyond the noise
that I've added, and
that can break things.
Let's see.
So now it's pretty much
just falling almost
as a passive pendulum, and
that breaks things more.
Although this is a
pretty easy problem.
That doesn't horribly
break anything.
OK, that same code could have
run for the acrobot, right?
It couldn't have run
for one of our airplanes
because the aerodynamics
tends to not be
linear in the parameters.
But rigid body dynamics tend
to be linear in the parameters,
right?
Doing it on the acrobot's
a little bit harder
because you have to be
more clever in stimulating
all the dynamics with
your one actuator.
So there are a lot
of good problems
left in system identification.
Designing sufficiently
rich inputs
to stimulate all your dynamics
is one of the big ones.
But function approximation
and least squares
is basically what you need to
do to do system identification.
AUDIENCE: So if you have,
for example, [INAUDIBLE]----
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
presumably, you
have sine theta minus as one
of the parts in your equations.
So if you want to get
something good, you,
should put that as one
of the features, right?
You have sine alpha minus gamma
there, and then [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE:
There's always a step
where you have to
look at your equations
and pull out the proper
basis function to describe
that class of systems.
Absolutely.
So if there's a sine
theta 1 minus theta 2
floating around in
there, it should
be in one of your basis--
as one of your basis elements.
AUDIENCE: If you want to
do this with this system
but you don't have
the knowledge,
you think that it's
linear, but you
don't know the equation for it.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
AUDIENCE: Then?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Then
maybe you should
do radial basis functions or
polynomials or some other basis
set.
I think a more common
thing would be,
imagine there's something
I'm not modeling well
in my pendulum.
Let's say there's some
nonlinear friction in the joints
or something like that.
A common thing that people would
do would be to add in here some
slop terms-- let's say radial
basis functions or something,
just in my standard linear
function approximator--
and do that, OK?
And then, now you've just added
more representational power
to this--
you've given the basis functions
which you believe to be true,
but you also add in
some slop terms, right?
And this is-- I mean, so Slotine
certainly teaches this and does
this in his robots, right?
For his adaptive
controller, he puts those in
to capture the terms that
he didn't expect to show up.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How well does
this work for things
that aren't really smooth.
Sometimes stick slope can--
it seems like if you
plot it, it's not really
a continuous function.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Continuous
doesn't matter, right?
If you were trying to fit
a continuous basis set
to a discontinuous
function, then it'll
only do as well as it can
in the least square sense.
But you can represent
arbitrary static functions of--
if it's a function of x,
then it should be right.
I think the more
common problem, maybe
in a stick slope kind of model,
is that there's hidden state--
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah.
RUSS TEDRAKE: --for
instance, right?
Maybe you don't know exactly
what the state of the system
is because there's some other--
and then you'd have to
estimate that to put it
into your basis set.
OK, people feel OK with
least squares estimation?
Yeah?
Good.
Now let's see if we
can put it to use
to do what we promised at
the beginning, which is
temporal difference learning.
It's gone, isn't it?
OK.
So if you remember, and I hope
the impression came across when
I was talking about temporal
difference learning,
that we made a pretty
complicated update, which
was this weighted sum of one
step, two step, three step,
end step returns through
some algebraic trick,
and that's really probably the
right way to think about it.
Through some
algebraic trick, you
could do it with a
very simple algorithm.
So let me just remind you
that that algorithm was--
OK.
So if you remember, the
picture we had last time
was that I've got some Markov
chain that I'm moving around.
As I'm walking around
this Markov chain,
I'm trying to-- every
time I visit a state,
I want to update my
estimate of the costs
to go from being in
that state, right?
And I can do it with this
very simple algorithm
which keeps a decaying
eligibility trace on each node.
Every time I visit
this node, it goes up.
And then it starts decaying
until the next time I visit
and it goes up.
The rate at which
it decays is given
by the discount factor in
my optimal control problem
and the lambda, which
is the amount that I
want to weight Monte Carlo--
long-term evaluations-- versus
short-term evaluations, right?
If lambda is 1, I'm going to let
that settle much more slowly,
and it's going to be making
very long-term updates,
and if lambda is
0, then it's just
going to make an update based
on the one-step prediction, OK?
If I carry around this
eligibility trace,
this would be ei as a
function of time for every i,
and I do this very
simple update,
then there's this interpretation
that j hat is doing something
between Monte Carlo and
one-step bootstrapping,
depending on what
lambda you pick.
Right?
OK, so let's say we don't have
a discrete state and action
system, but we now
have, let's say
our barycentric interpolator
is on a pendulum
or something like that, right?
And let's say I take a
trajectory through here,
which I-- that was a bad
trajectory for a phase space,
but I take some trajectory
through my state space, OK?
Let's say I'm willing to
discretize the system in time
still.
And let's say my value
estimate is a linear function
approximator here, which is
this barycentric grid, OK?
So at every point
here, I'm going
to say j hat is just a weighted
combination of the four
neighboring points weighted
by the distance, right?
Like I said, that
actually is exactly
of the form where I've
got a scalar output,
and I've just got-- you
can think of this as being
a tent, this being a
basis function which
has sort of a tent of region
of applicability right here,
and added with this one that has
a tent of applicability here.
And at every point, there's
a-- at every cross-hair,
there's a basis function
that looks like a tent.
Did you get that out
of the previous one--
the previous picture?
Linearly interpolating
between those four points
is the same as saying I've
got four basis functions that
are active, and each
of them contributes
in a way that diminishes
from their point of attack.
OK.
So now I've got a linear
function approximator
trying to estimate j hat.
So how could I possibly
do temporal distance
learning-- yeah, John.
AUDIENCE: Is that
volumetric interpolation?
Barycentric has smaller--
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, good.
So you can do barycentric
in three or four, actually.
AUDIENCE: And here, you
have-- this would be-- you'd
have three points, though,
right, in this problem?
RUSS TEDRAKE: This would
still be called barycentric,
but it's true the barycentric
we did before was just,
you take the neighboring
three points.
It's true.
So actually, you can do
barycentric with the three
neighboring points or the four
neighboring points or whatever.
The volumetric is
actually also called--
is also a barycentric
interpolator.
But you're right.
I should have been more careful.
The way we did
barycentric before is we
took the three closest
points, not the four, right?
Taking the four is also
a good interpolator.
It also is called a barycentric
interpolator, actually, right?
And the question is just
how it grows with the state.
Most people use the
three closest points
because then, in
higher dimensions,
it's always n plus 1 points
instead of the powers of n.
Good, thank you.
OK.
So I guess, then, the
domain of attraction
is more like that
or something, right?
For every cross-hair,
there's a--
if you're doing the
triangle interpolation,
then it's more like that.
Yeah?
So what do you think?
So how can we make an
analogy between going
through discrete states
and increasing eligibility?
This eligibility is really--
I just need to remember
that that state was
relevant in my history of costs.
Can you think of
an analogy of how
this function approximator
might play into those equations?
What I want to get to with
function approximation,
I want to get an
update for alpha
that has the same sort of form.
This j, remember, was--
in the Markov chain
case, that's a vector j,
where each element of the vector
was the cost to go estimate
for the i-th node, right?
Now my function
approximator is-- again,
I'm trying to estimate
a vector alpha,
but each alpha could
potentially affect my estimate
in multiple states.
The power of function
approximators
is you don't have to consider
every point individually.
You get some generalization.
One parameter affects
multiple outputs.
OK?
So what could possibly
make this tick?
How would you do temporal
difference learning
with function approximators?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Before, we
were basically doing it through
basis functions that
were deltas at every--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
AUDIENCE: --point.
So you can break
j hat up into be
something that is actually based
on these other basis functions.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So this should
be-- whatever we come up
with, this should hopefully
be the limiting case where,
if my basis function
was delta functions,
you'd like to get back to that?
I think that's,
unfortunately, going to be a--
AUDIENCE: OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: No, no.
Well, it just happens I'm going
to be taking gradients, so--
but yeah, that's very-- that's
a very nice observation,
actually.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: I think you can't
erase because that [INAUDIBLE]
Kronecker delta, so it's--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Exactly, yeah.
AUDIENCE: By delta function,
he meant infinity or 1?
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's what
John was pointing out.
So he thinks it's going to be
a Kronecker delta because it's
going to have--
I guess it could be 1, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if it
is 1, it's actually--
it would be mapping from
a Tableau representation
to the actual function
approximation.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But having features
that are just 1, and you say--
RUSS TEDRAKE: No,
I think that's--
I think it's a very
nice observation.
If we think of each feature as
having height 1 here and domain
nothing, right, then that
should be the limiting case
where we get our Markov chain.
I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: So if you just
changed to taking, at each step,
a weighted sum of nodes--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --then mapping that
weighted sum, [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, I mean,
that's effectively right.
So the way that you
can do it turns out
to be a little bit-- again, a
little bit nice and magical,
OK?
So it turns out--
so there's a couple of
ways to think about this.
One of them is when I'm
going through the Markov
chain, every time
I get here, I'm
going to think forward about--
I'm going to do a
one-step prediction,
two-step prediction,
I'm going to do a
three-step prediction.
And what happens is that these
eligibility traces are just
this trick which
makes all that work.
If I just remember
where I've been,
then I can make an update, which
is the same as looking forward.
Instead, I'm
looking back in time
with my eligibility traces.
In the function
approximator case,
doing exactly what
you said turns out
to be equivalent
to remembering how
important that parameter alpha
i was in your recent history.
OK?
Does that make sense?
If I remember the
contribution that alpha made--
let's say one of the elements
of alpha, alpha i, alpha j--
made in my recent
history, then I
can update alpha in
the same sort of trick
that this eligibility
trace worked on for.
AUDIENCE: Would you do some
kind of decaying exponential?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's kind of
what it's doing there.
RUSS TEDRAKE: This is
exactly what it's doing here.
And here, we had
the special case
where when I visited
the state, I got a 1,
and when I didn't
visit it, I get here.
I got nothing.
It just decayed.
And what we're going to get
now is an eligibility trace
on alpha.
Do you have it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean,
does this thing in brackets
need to be changed at all?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: It seems like delta--
RUSS TEDRAKE: The
eligibility trace changes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Perfect, right?
This is gamma.
It's going to do a
decaying exponential still.
You want to forget things.
This thing is now--
the new eligibility trace here
is the same size as alpha,
not the number of
nodes in the system.
And the amount that I'm going
to credit each alpha with
is the gradient of my estimate.
Does that sort of make sense?
Yeah?
In the case of linear
function approximators,
the gradient of this
is just phi of x.
Partial j, partial alpha.
Just gets rid of that alpha.
OK?
So I remember the
relative contribution
of each of my alphas
in the recent past,
and then, based on this
e, I make the same update
that I did before.
Just copy this down.
But my e is now the
eligibility on alpha.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] based on
that one to the one that gets
visited and zero to the others.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Which is what?
What's that?
Yeah?
OK.
So that is an intuitively
correct algorithm, I think.
So it seems pretty natural,
using the eligibility argument,
that this could work.
Proving that it works
turns out to be a pain.
It's not actually an update
like we would normally have.
There's a special case.
So in one case, when
lambda equals 1,
then you can actually
show that this TD
update with linear
function approximation
is doing gradient descent on
the difference between my j
lambda--
what I call j lambda--
and my other j squared.
OK?
So in the lambda versus
1 case, it actually
is doing gradient descent
on the Monte Carlo error.
In every other
setting of lambda,
the algorithm is not a
standard optimization framework
of going down in some steepest
descent kind of approach.
But it tends-- in
some cases, it works
faster because it uses previous
information in a heuristic
sort of way, but it does
it very effectively.
And people have done the work.
In fact, the work
was done upstairs
by Tsitsiklis and Van Roy in
'97 or something like this
to prove that, for all
lambdas between 0 and 1
in linear function
approximators,
that this update will go
to the true value estimate
as your system runs.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Did they mention
that the [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: They should.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I guess
different algorithms can reach
a different result,
and lambda equals
1 only converges to the actual
thing that you're looking for.
As you start varying
lambda, you converge
toward different
things, but it's
still converging [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
possible, but--
AUDIENCE: Different lambdas?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I mean--
AUDIENCE: Once
your [INAUDIBLE] is
correct, doesn't lambda
not matter anymore?
Because it's going to
project to the future--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, the
only stationary point
should be the true
cost to go function.
So if it converges--
I'd be surprised if that's true.
AUDIENCE: Your
lambda [INAUDIBLE]----
RUSS TEDRAKE: I mean,
Alborz has done the stuff,
so you might know
it better than I do.
But I was under the impression
it converges to the true value
estimate.
I mean, it's all based on
these contraction mappings,
and I think the stationary
point of the contraction
is the true value.
If you find out
differently, then
tell us next class, definitely.
OK.
So what just happened?
So I made a trivial
change to the algorithm.
In fact, in some ways,
it looks almost easier.
It's one less line.
And it now suddenly works with
linear function approximators.
So I don't have to feel like
I discretized my state space.
I can cover my state space
with radial basis functions.
That might be as
painful, by the way,
as discretizing the
state space if you
have to put a lot of radial
basis functions down.
But I could also do it
with more complicated--
I could do it with
polynomials, I could do it
with Fourier bases,
and potentially,
things that work with
less basis functions
over a very large domain.
And now suddenly,
the tools scale up
to little bit higher
dimensional systems,
as high as you can imagine.
As creative as your basis
set allows you to be.
To complain about
these algorithms
is that they're inefficient
in their use of data.
So if you think--
certainly when we're shooting
planes and they break,
or if we're using a walking
robot and it falls down a lot,
then every piece of data should
be treated with reverence,
right?
This is hard-earned data.
These algorithms, as written
like this, basically,
every time they
visit the data, they
make some small
incremental update,
and a throw it away
and keep moving.
And so, by no means are
they efficient in data.
They are efficient
only in the sense
that they use previous
estimates of j hat to bootstrap,
but there's no sense of
remembering all your data
and reusing it.
So some people have thought
about replaying trajectories.
So if you store all your
trajectories-- let's
say I ran my plane
10 times, well,
I'll remember all that
data and I'll just
run the TD update over and
over again over those same 10
trajectories.
That's a reasonable thing to do.
But again, with linear
function approximators,
you can do better, right?
You can do LSTD, least squares
temporal difference learning.
This is least squares temporal
difference learning, yeah?
The argument basically
goes like this.
So in learning, there's
always a difference--
people like to
distinguish between online
versus batch updates.
So the online-- this
is an online update.
I took my piece of data in.
I immediately changed alpha
and then I spat it out, right?
You could imagine a "batch"
update, which collected
a bunch of these trajectories.
Let's say it ran a whole
trajectory with the plane.
Stop.
Now process that trajectory,
make a change in alpha,
and then repeat.
So instead of doing it at
every single time step,
let's collect a little bit of
data and then make an update,
OK?
So let's just write down
what a batch update--
the batch update for this
system, if I ran a trajectory
and then made an
update, that update
would look like this,
just by applying
that rule a bunch of times
but without changing alpha
in between, right?
So another way to say it is
I'm going to hold alpha fixed,
collect up all
the changes I want
to make at alpha, and then,
at the end of the run,
make one change to alpha, OK?
Well, then that change, if
you do it in the batch mode,
is just going to be a
sum of all these guys.
That's a scalar times a vector.
So I can reorder it
without any pain.
Oops.
I got to put that inside.
Let me write out the
intermediate step here.
j alpha ik plus 1
minus j alpha ik.
Agree with that?
That's the batch update of that.
I just collect them all
up, I sum them over k here,
all my time steps.
That's what my update's
going to look like.
If I write this a
little bit-- if I
break into my function
approximator there,
I can write it like this.
hm over k.
Oh, boy, I forgot
my ek over here.
Sorry about that.
There's an ek there too, right?
j is just phi times alpha, so
I'm going to break into that.
If I collect those terms,
then I get something
we can think about again.
Sorry, a times alpha, where this
is b and this guy here is a.
In other words, the long-term
behavior of this system,
if I collect the updates and
then make them like this,
well, this looks like
a low-pass filter,
really, that's going
to this solution.
Yeah.
The steady state is alpha
equals a inverse phi,
where you do that
inverse carefully.
svd or something.
OK.
So that observation led
to this least squares
temporal difference
learning algorithm,
which said instead of chewing
up every piece of-- every data
point and spitting it
out, remember everything
that you have
experienced in the past.
And instead of doing this
sort of incremental step
that goes epsilon
towards the steady state,
you can solve for
that steady state
every time you have--
if you collect b and a,
you can just collect that
with a bunch of data,
go ahead and jump
right to the solution.
So LSTD, what I
think a lot of people
would consider the
state of the art
if you just want to
do policy evaluation,
build up b and a as you run.
Compute alpha is a inverse
b whenever you need
a new estimate of alpha, OK?
Why do you want to do that?
It's more efficient
with your data.
You remember and replay
your last data seamlessly.
You don't have to guess
some silly learning rate.
And it doesn't even depend
on your initial conditions
anymore, your initial
guess at alpha.
OK?
So if I went to go and do--
if I were given a robot
that's currently performing
some feedback controller.
Let's say it's stochastic.
It's a stochastic system.
There's noise and
everything like that.
And I wanted to just evaluate
how well it performed
on this cost function, some cost
function that someone gave me.
If [INAUDIBLE] says
I got this robot,
I wanted it to optimize
this cost function.
How is it doing?
Tell me how it's doing.
I would look at that--
I would look at the state space.
I'd try to come up with a
linear tiling of radial basis
functions, or some
linear function
approximator over
that state space,
and I'd start running trials
and I'd keep those trials
and store up these matrices,
and do a least squares
temporal difference update.
And this result
basically tells me
that it's going to do
the same thing as the TD.
It's going to do it potentially
more effectively because it's
more efficient
with data, and it's
going to do it without having
to guess initial vector
or having some learning rate.
AUDIENCE: Do you
actually have to define
the length of an
episode, for example,
if it's a periodic system
like a walking system?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE:
That's really good.
So Alborz here has
actually written
a paper on incremental LSTD.
So you might think that doing
that update is expensive,
and it can be if you
just naively do that.
But you can do
recursively squares,
and you can sort of make
a cheaper online update
to try to do this, to make this
a constant update of alpha.
If you choose to update
alpha at every step, which
you could choose to do,
and maybe you would choose
to do on a non-episodic
task, or maybe in walking,
you do it once per
step or whatever,
then you can do it nicely
with an incremental LSTD.
And you can look
at Alborz's paper
to figure out how
to do that, which
is an approximation
of the true LSTD,
but a pretty good one in
your experiments, right?
And much more efficient, right?
Yeah, or there's a lot of time--
I mean, I think, in
walking, it turns out
I would do it probably
once per step or something.
There's natural discretizations.
But there's nothing
to say, if you
have the computational
horsepower, that you couldn't
just do this every step too.
It's just more expensive than
doing an incremental version.
OK?
So function approximation's
very powerful.
This is what's going to
take our tabular based ideas
and our Markov
chain ideas and make
them scale to the real world.
This is the first year I did
function approximation first
in the temporal
different learning case,
but of course it's relevant
for the policy gradient world
too, right?
John showed you different
function approximators
that were doing reinforce.
Instead of parameterizing my
value function as a function
approximator, I could have also
just directly parameterized
my feedback controller
as a value function,
and done gradient
descent if I had a model,
or reinforce if I
didn't have a model.
Function approximation
is supposed
to be the savior of
reinforcement learning.
The problem is there's
limited results.
I mean, the linear
function approximation
is really the only case we
have strong results for most
of these cases.
So I'm going to talk about doing
the policy stuff with function
approximation on
Thursday, and then
it culminates in actor-critic,
where you do both function
approximation in the
policy and the value
function simultaneously.
That'll happen
sometime next week.
Excellent.
I'll see you next week.